welcome to this video yeah this is a
video featuring one of my over the board
games played recently in them european
club cap in bilbao spain a great event
before i'm starting with the actual
content of the video i'd like to quickly
mention as you have seen already the
different layout here of this video i'm
trying a new platform and i think i'm
going to stick with this platform for
most of them analysis content it's the
lettuces board of chess calm it has some
advantages over the platform that I used
up to now the main advantages that I can
hear prepare PGN fat easily and load it
into the whole thing with their
variation so it makes it easier for me
to present the prepared content and this
PGN file i would also attached to the
video so you can look at the description
and if you won't load this PGN into your
PGN viewer or if you want on chess.com
on there on the NL is a spot the same
meds i'm i'm using then you can look at
it and to maybe check things with the
computer on or just think of your own
about the moose um yeah please so if it
kept feedback on those this layout is
very much welcome i made sure that the
screen real estate is used properly and
the board is as big as possible of
course with white screen nowadays some
squared chessboard will always be a bit
tricky some space will always be um yeah
unused goodbye by a board on the on the
left or right inside and that try to
make it as a as good as possible this
loud okay let's start with the actual
game um the european club cap is a
seven-round swiss event for teams of the
sleep club cup
and I only joined for the third round so
my team had already played two rounds I
judged only for the third round and
played the final five rounds because I
had a commitment in the German leak so i
arrived late and then played rounds
three to seven so this is my first game
of the tournament but the third round of
the event but irritating maybe um yeah
we were playing an English team and I
was playing am also a player from
England um it's not the same I mean
those teams are full of international
players that can happen that you play a
team from you know Italy and there's no
Italian in there okay i'm playing a Liam
varnum on the English player been rated
about 2000 and I'm sorry 120 enter let's
get right into the action we were
playing a Sicilian which is not so
common for me I normally play a 5 double
king porn but in my preparation I had
noticed something I can put up what I'm
played a plate there's a salient con
variation with a six and I had
recognized that my opponent normally we
put this on the board but we actually
played let my opponent normally against
other sicilian lines he liked to play
the the English attack with Bishop e3
and f3 and the singing con is a tricky
line that prevents the English attack
funny enough if white now tries to play
in this style with Bishop e3 is getting
hit by this this direct attack on c3 and
very quickly his center will come under
huge pressure of course this is
something that my opponent also knows he
tended to avoid this in in earlier games
but he played pretty inoffensive setups
then he played Bishop e2 for example
which is not a bad move but not very
ambitious or he played something
like this which is really giving black a
very easy game with with things like b5
and a quick Bishop d7 coming so I was
sort of speculating that he was doing
one of those um not very ambitious
ambitious tries but then he played
Bishop d3 so my gamble didn't really
paid off this is a main line and
unfortunately not something that I
really know um what I do didn't know is
that now knight c6 as a move but I
played that and I knew that they very
often play Bishop e3 yet I was hoping
for that because after Bishop e3 I'm
going Knight f6 castles and then
something like age 5 intending this
funny idea this is at least something
that I would have known a bit as I have
played this line now which is supposed
to tomorrow so you have played this line
years ago and at least I would have had
some idea what to do but he didn't do
that he jumped a little bit too far back
after 96 he took on c6 and jam here I'm
yeah I'm faced with the dilemma because
I don't like any recapture b.tech see is
possible after castles black plays
something like I five and i'm not sure
that they're like the combination of the
moves Queen c7 he and his success looks
very slow for the structure it is a
probably objectively okay but it's
nothing that i particularly like and
greet aches I didn't really consider I
am afterwards learned that this is
played sometimes I mean Grisha played it
just a couple of years ago and something
like like this happened and then he went
with the night to g6 yeah maybe no I
actually prefer that to to what I played
in the game but
it's a gap it's nothing great for black
really um yeah add at the end I decided
to take with the deep own or pretty
quickly I decided to take with the deep
on simply because I disliked be takes
and Queen takes I didn't really think
about yeah now after castles and e5 we
get a pretty normal looking position
here we have an open D file and pretty
symmetrical porn structure on the Kings
side um what is a bit tricky is what
white is doing next he played now f form
so you played an active move yeah not
any passive move it should be 3 or
anything but f form and this is just a
good a good move I am not very well
developed and I should catch up and
development as soon as possible I went
Knight f6 and now he played the move f5
that's a good move it's much better than
for example taking on e5 this looks good
at first because you might think that
Queenie 5 Bishop f4 is is annoying and
wide get some gets a tempo on the Queen
and maybe can push a 5 after my queen
has moved but black has the move Knight
g4 which is much stronger after Knight
g4 I can take with the night back on e5
and have this this excellent night
square on e5 later so the capture is is
really not a good idea what wyd should
do and what he did do is to play f5 you
went f5 and now we see the big problem
of my setup at least I perceived it as a
big problem this is a position that has
been played dozens of times by good
players as black but I don't like it
it's just like that and they don't like
it because while my bishop is always
biting on this pawn I have no natural
development now with the bishop is six
bet it would want to be tonight
do that and I don't really know where to
deploy this Bishop actively of course
what I can do and what um lots of
players play now is to go for set up
with be five yeah so they often give the
check as I did I also go give the check
on c5 King h1 and then a a typical way
to play here is b-52 maybe get the
bishop to be seven however I was unsure
how good this really is because I always
ask myself if if he goes a four in this
position which is a pretty normal way to
play attacking this pawn structure how
do I react I don't want to play before
giving up the c-4 square maybe I need to
but I really don't like to do that
giving up this square here maybe yeah a
knight can later come there this is the
wrong this is the wrong route it I mean
this to be one to d2 and then to see for
I had this kind of this kind of way I
don't like to give up this and I I don't
know if I'm here how do I ever get my
bishop activated I cannot play c5 as
then the pressure on b5 gets too big so
I'm not sure maybe I'm just not
understanding the position correctly but
I don't like it yeah I went h5 in the
game this might look yet but it has some
ideas the twofold I mean one is this
maybe I can sometimes activate mine I'd
like that threaten on f2 sometimes the H
pawn can be a nuisance for white the
rookies use basically on its original
square here and the other thing that
worried me a bit is that white maybe
play something like this to attack the
g7 porn they wanted to put it on age 42
to control the g3 square um yeah h5 in
fact is also played there so I played
couple of theoretical moves without
really knowing it he went Bishop g5 and
I played age form yeah according to them
to the plan that I have then ahead black
can't play Knight g4 but after Queenie
to now something like that after Queenie
to it really does not lead to lead to
much so I think in comparison from age
four is better he went Queen dear three
and yeah as mentioned i wasn't really
very enthusiastic of Pluto about playing
be five so I went Bishop d7 a very
humble move but what I want to do is
just rope the aid or cancelling long and
get the the rukon a aid until the game
played Bishop b3 and yeah this this
actually did surprise me a bit um that
you would play Bishop g5 and then back
but it is in fact not a bad idea
strategically speaking it gets rid of my
bishop on c5 and they basically have to
trade em in what else is there i took
and now the queen has a good position
only three really it looks at those
critical squares and it supports these
kind of ideas the night might come to a
form and then jump jump from there to
the week squares on c5 and b6 yeah and
also somewhat discouraged my idea to
Castle long it didn't want one dead now
I mean my queen side looks looks weak um
I played rock dat I think this is okay
rook the eighth you play tonight a4 and
as planned Bishop c8 so I got in the egg
edge rock into the game and this is
playing now and the bishop on CL is not
yeah not great but it's not something
that cannot be solved later maybe at a
later stage be 65 Bishop e7 this was
what I was thinking not easy to do at
the moment because it has this grip on
the on the critical square c5 and b6 so
how to assess the position
I think why probably is slightly better
you should be slightly more comfortable
here but nothing really dramatic has
happened yet so um I I wasn't very yeah
thrilled about all of it especially I
was playing the Sicilian to get a
somewhat more dynamic game and it didn't
happen I was still having sort of a
symmetrical position where I'm where I'm
a little bit worse always the kind of
thinking I could have gotten that with
your usual stuff anyway okay played rook
t1 make sense putting it on the D file
yeah but I'm not totally sure about my
next maneuver but what I wanted to do is
to sort of make sure that his nidus is
getting back yeah Ruby 495 and Queenie 7
which pushes the night back a bit or
provokes a move like c3 c3 em now he
could have played as well but he went
nite b3 it's also okay it's just ok
rucca t6 and now he played a strong move
it's a simple move but it's still strong
he played but should be too this is just
a good improving move why does covering
this important square so I don't have
written an item g4 counter play and he
intends to exchange the rukon v6 I
really don't have anything else than
capturing yeah he will exchange my
active rook and replace it it and
replaces it with this own work so I
exchanged and now they don't only that
this is all all nice with the H file and
and the rook supporting the porn but
while the D file I need a rook on the
default badly so I castled the point is
that he cannot easily win the pawn here
on an unknown age form as I'm always
counter attacking the e4 pawn this is in
fact why the position is still quite
okay for black the knight on f6 is
attacking here
d4 pawn which is a weakness as well and
another point that definitely is
important it gets very very important
later in the game is that this h4 pond
is slightly cramping his his King side
his King is not so secure my king is
more secure than his if you imagine a
queen entering the position they will
better back rank ideas and maybe aged 3
to irritate and we will see all of that
later it looks very or sounds very
abstract at the moment but it's
definitely a case whenever white pushes
the f porn in the sicilian with a short
catholic position he tends to open his
King so this I think is still about
balanced maybe white has a slight edge
but it's nothing too dramatic however
the game now being pretty logical up to
this point now gets very irrational he
plays Queen d3 that sets the rationale
yeah using the default doubling the day
on the D file and yeah here we come to
the first point why I am where I started
to UM started to to play a mare slightly
risky moves I here quickly decided to
play Queen before activating the Queen
I'm sorry and that's not that bad but it
seems that c5 was probably advise a
choice that ideas to put the the bishop
on c6 and it's a good moment for this
move as Queen d6 now is said tricky
because he just blunders the pawn this
is what I was mentioning earlier i have
this counter threats against the e4 pawn
and this seems to be a bit better than
what i did mike we be formal is not
terrible but it's not really
giving me much benefits if we look at
the game he played this really well now
he played Bishop f3 my original idea
with Queen B form by the way was then
after Bishop f3 I wanted to play Bishop
f5 it would be fantastic to play because
it would solve all of my problems
immediately my problems immediately this
this is a stupid c8 bishop would come in
with the sacrifice and after this yeah
fantastic i'm getting the piece back and
even open the whole position for maybe a
later play on his King however this has
a huge hole this kind of idea and this
is a 3 mm-hmm okay I need to move the
Queen and now he has got this and I'm
losing a piece yeah let's say I have
given up peace I'm not getting it back
fortunately I recognize this as often
hear you recognize your fault right away
right after you played this I recognize
the weight I cannot take on f5 so okay I
had to do something else and I thought
of I really liked the idea so I went b6
yeah this is not working I went b6 the
idea is that now this is threatening
yeah I'm covering those those squares on
c5 and a 5 so if he does something
something really unimportant like that
let's say I can't do that because now
there is no 95 and black has a good
position so b6 based on this idea Bishop
takes a 5 however it's not really
leading to much I could have played
rookie aid instead which is simpler and
stood about equal he played didn't play
age 30 40 played a 3 this is stronger
attacking the Queen I went to a forum
and he went 92 yeah and here
we have a position where he's intending
to play Knight to c4 activating the
night and here I really fail to
appreciate the strength of the
smoothness nights he fumbles I played
queen bee hive here it seems that
probably 85 was was a better choice the
idea is to to get this in which of
course also was an idea of might be six
moves yet to get this thing set up maybe
activating this bishop after a five
white has this funny move intending
Knight c3 trapping my queen yeah this is
really a problem my queen it's not
totally trapped i can go to d4 but it
costs a pawn I probably should
immediately get this going and this is a
really interesting line now I'm
threatening bishop at five and white
really has no way to prevent that I'm
getting getting a porn back that way but
if we consider this we see that in this
line yeah something like that why it is
just better he's definitely calling the
shots iam the bishop is stronger than
the night and this paw information is
potentially week I'm not lost here or
anything but it's a very unattractive
position to play still a five is better
than what i did i played the move to be
five let me go back to that i played
this move after which she naturally
replied night see for what I have failed
to appreciate was I went a five which
which are planned and what I didn't
really see is that the move Queen B 3
now would have been very interesting he
played that but queen bee three would
have been would have been very
interesting the idea simply to take on
b5 and then take off one of those pawns
and yeah what exactly is my reply
huh not easy Quincy five is in fact the
best move and this is a very tricky move
and I'm not so sure if I would have
played all that the big point is that
now Knight takes b6 it's not that great
in fact because I can sacrifice here
it's a very very unusual IDM then Queen
f2 and it turns out that white all of a
sudden is not that coordinated yeah
something like Bishop c4 there's this
knight f form an IG for I'm sorry
intending this move and black has a
great counter play all of a son so night
takes b6 isn't really good it's very
very surprising but white can play
better i can play 83 m and now i'm still
sitting there i don't know what to do
about their pod now this is a real
threat and it seems that the best movie
is is g6 given by the computer and it's
just the thing that it's not clear if I
would have found all that so why puts me
under huge pressure to find those moves
the idea of this is if why it takes yeah
um I have Bishop b6 very a very nice
point yeah white white still has a can
play a queen III takes Queen 86 this
kind of thing is all very very
interesting but it's just about okay for
black but it yeah and it would have
taken me some effort to find that what
he played is b3 and this is less testing
after be three I could have had I could
have gotten a pretty pretty easy game or
let's say as a satisfactory game is not
like mm and better or what but I should
have just played Quincy five now which
unfortunately i didn't but Quincy five
now would have been okay
of course I wanted to go to c5 but I had
a more ambitious idea which I ever had a
big hole yeah Quincy five is just better
the idea is to have a look at this pawn
have a look here yeah the dark squares
or weekend ones can but maybe be five at
the right moment after that I'm probably
still okay it's nothing terrible
happening to me for example here you can
can play a queen III can trade it should
be seven right there c5 and i'm getting
a counter-attack against before going
what i mentioned earlier this is also
weakens in whites camp this probably
will lead to a position which is about
equal however i played the move a form a
form that's what I played and now I need
to mention the absolute key thing about
the disposition and what happens
afterwards the absolute most important
thing of this now was not the position
on the board it was I mean the position
of the pot is always very important but
it was very important to know that at
this point I had probably around 30 to
40 minutes left we were playing with 90
minutes for 40 moves and 30 second
increment I had thought 30 minutes 40
minutes I know lots of time left and my
opponent he was down to a little bit
more than his increment like maybe a
minute or so he had spent tons of time
earlier and he was was visibly nervous
and this really affected the play very
considerably because I still didn't like
my position very much and i felt that i
maybe should complicate matters to to
irritate him with little time on the
clock maybe provoke some mistake and
this made me play also very quickly and
i made some
some mistakes in the process a4 is one
of those what I didn't appreciate after
after a voice that he can now play a
very strong move it's not a very
difficult move once you see it but it it
was still missed by the him with little
time on the clock he captured on a
forward White has a strong move in Queen
III once you see it it's very apparent
that this is strong it it takes b6 and
what exactly am i doing yeah I can take
on b3 from what ya like like you capture
and now after c5 there's just this one
falling and what exactly is my move now
I can i can try something like bishop 86
but line like that is just not very
attractive i'm down upon c6 is falling
and my coordination is is how horrible
there's also this one this one coming
yeah Queen III was a very strong very
strong move by am for white he took on a
5 forever on a 4 i'm sorry and i went to
see five so i wanted to go to c5 anyway
but i wanted to insert this I never have
never considered Queen III which is of
course quite embarrassing it's a pretty
simple move to spot um ok here it seems
I'm okay again really this extra porn is
not giving white much I wanted to go
here because I wanted to threaten Bishop
a6 immediately yeah using this pin he
went here and i went to Bishop a6 this
was my plan activating this Bishop yeah
he now has some has this night hanging
and it went to d6 yeah this is this
active this active post and this is what
I what I wanted to have on the board
really because I thought that this night
looks good on d6 but it has nowhere to
go it's quite funny at a text f7 but if
you look at it up awk square sexy for
that controlled by a black pieces and I
was always thinking that I should have
some counter chances with Queen f2 maybe
Bishop e2 or h3 this kind of counter
attacking ideas and I was briefly
considering a queen F to hear ya Queen
f2 and thought that okay this should
probably be okay i have Bishop e2 i have
83 and then all of a sudden I mean look
at this for maybe 20 30 seconds or
something and then all of a sudden I got
an idea and my idea the idea was what
about if I play and I played that I play
King age 7 yeah and what about this and
I was thinking I isn't this a good idea
yeah I'm getting out of this F getting
away from the f7 porn and now I'm
threatening rook t8 using this this
opinion on the D file on the night and
isn't this a very difficult move to
answer for wide after night f7 yeah I
have Bishop c4 and winning winning this
piece back and not back and winning it
yeah was my was my idea at least and he
had as mentioned yet like 30 seconds on
the clock he was only getting the
increment back all the time for like one
or two moves already and I just then
quickly decided to play this king age 70
I didn't really think about this more
than a minute or so and this is of
course just pure gambling and not really
good chess I really should have
considered this this much longer and
yeah that the big point is I mean s you
may already have seen after King age
seven white can really capture after
Bishop c4 he gives this check King to
age 6 yeah otherwise I'm just don't
material and now we just place King see
the Queen's III and the problem is
yeah the night mm-hmm I can take it but
what about this this is a maid that I
can play this but no I'm checkmated with
the Queen Queen only three giving
checkmate to the king so yeah it was a
very very stupid very stupid decision to
play King XM however as I mentioned he
had 30 seconds and he probably had
thought before hand and this is
happening very often you think about
some other booths and you sort of with
your time you have a plan made out for
the other move and he just played what
he intended to do anyway he went not
night of seven but you played c4 he was
thinking about this idea anyway to block
my bishop yeah so that it's not coming
in this is not such a terrible move in
itself is just not using this chance
with night f7 that was presented to him
yeah and now I went quickly rook t8 as
as mentioned of course I was oblivious
that night f7 was working because it
happened so quickly I only saw that
afterwards after the game roop the eight
and how is in this pin and my idea was
that now after night f7 which she didn't
play could have played I will take
recaptures yeah Bishop Bishop takes
shows one of the ideas with black
winning already with night f2 coming so
Queen takes Bishop takes can give this
check and did this kind of position is
just a is just a mess yeah very very
tough to play especially with no time on
the clock and this was what I was hoping
for trying to get a super complicated
thing going with him having no time on
the clock basically playing a sort of
blitz game yeah and hoping to be the one
with the bed and nerves and and so on
but it didn't happen he played a
different he played Queen to b4
a good move by the way he really played
this okay queen before and here again
it's a situation i had 30 minutes he had
30 seconds and i was just thinking okay
it's clear i cannot treat queens and I
shouldn't allow him to take on on c5 so
I should move the Queen and I was
thinking okay to e3 ought to f2 and I
quickly decided to play Queen III as it
turns out Queen f2 was the right move
after Queen f2 I probably have a good
enough position or an active enough
position to draw the game yeah one one
thing that that might happen is a ch3
that's very sensible getting some some
lift for the king and making sure I
don't play h3 ya hear a good line is
root d7 very important move it keeps f7
protected and sort of asks white what
are you doing next it also prepares and
some some situations may be 98 using the
pin now not not so easy to get in but
possible yeah King age to probably and
now maybe Queen III intending to to give
this check and keeping b6 protected here
black has enough activity to keep the
game the game balance in the game
however I didn't play that I am very
quickly decided to to dash out a move I
played Queen III and Queenie 3s again a
big mistake and here he he could have
gotten a large advantage with the move
rookie one rookie one yeah this would
have been strong and the big point is
after wookie one I play Queen f2 and he
really can take this
and this is what he didn't didn't
consider in the in the game um the the
problem is if you have absolutely no
time on the clock you tend to see ghosts
and here this looks very dangerous for
white afternoon tea too yeah I'm
attacking the rook all of a sudden and i
have this age 3 idea and the the thing
is white here has a very reliable
defense with the passive looking move
rook to g1 it looks it looks better but
it's just just keeping the whole thing
together I now have no active
possibility the big point is that move
like Age 3 which might look tricky is
simply refuted by 95 check and he's
taking with the night with a very easy
win so rookie one now was very very
strong he however didn't play that well
he had no time on the clock he played
not this one he played a five and with a
five he overlooked a tactic and yeah but
I had seen the tactic but he overlooked
it the problem was that now I could take
on a five and here we realized that his
original idea was not working what he of
course wanted to do he wanted to just
take him and ask this Bishop a very
embarrassing question of what what are
you doing this and this rook is also
hanging it looks terrible but the
problem is it's not working White is
losing now due to a tactic and this
tactic is maybe something that you can
try to spot on your own if you want the
tactic is rook takes d6 yeah and after
rook takes these six Knight takes e4
black is winning I can made him on the
back rank if he captures on your form
and the rook is attacked and I'm
threatening the
good old smothered mate so something
like that yeah that was very unlucky for
wine that this plant moved Quint eggs at
five was not working this is what I was
mentioning but not earlier that White's
King position is a little bit insecure
and this is got to him at the end here
it's it's really already very
problematic for White he went Queen d2
yeah was with one second on the clock i
think i remember one or two seconds he
had left and now i can take on a three
and this is why i went to e3 in the
first place i wanted to have this
lateral attack as well yeah Queen takes
a three and now black has as a pawn I'm
ever got an extra porner all of a sudden
and the main thing is this is a terrible
pin my idea now is simply to play look
98 at the right moment and a twin the
night with this pin and here he was
visibly upset yeah that he had sport the
position and went when Queen f2 which
just gives away in the night yeah but it
really does not matter that much anymore
it's a blunder but wyd now is lost i can
play group d 798 this kind of ideas he
went here and i just took it after some
more moves him wide resigned so this was
the the first game of this event and a
very very lucky win white had numerous
ways to to win the game um and it's a
clear um a clear demonstration how how
bad time management can can get you he
would have easily won this game um if he
had more time on the clock after after
around to move 30 however it also needs
to be said that if he had more time on
the clock there like 10 minutes or so I
definitely wouldn't have played those
those blitz type of moves
as well I was really speculating that he
would be in trouble to find those moves
in 30 seconds I didn't want to spend
like five minutes and give him the
opportunity to think on my time this
kind of gambling attitude is
questionable but it sometimes can can
can get results like you see him in this
game it was in fact questionable because
at the spots where I made those gambling
moves I had decent a continuation that I
could play playing quickly in the
opponent's time trouble if you have time
on the clock make some sense if you
really have a totally lost position to
keep the pressure on but I didn't really
have a totally lost position so it
wasn't really a something that I should
be particularly proud of okay this was
the first game for me in this event and
the coming days i will show you the the
other games they were all interesting
there was no dull or an eventful game
among them and i can i can already
assure you that this was the only game
hair was exceptionally lucky in okay i
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching